TJ asks how would you suggest an indie  artists use their marketing money when  the royalty check comes in six months  later Jay first of all thank you for the  music today big ups to him and the  royalty check coming six months later  how do I think you should execute on  that is very simple I think you should  execute six months of patience if you  don't the money you just wait for it to  come and then you execute there is a  lack wordplay Jay and everybody else is  watching there is a lack of patience the  thought that your royal teach it comes  six months later means that whatever you  wanted to do with that money's you know  to attack just has to wait six months  and so practically I just wait